- There's a kind of feeling
for the ambition of this
interdisciplinary work
that often is very happy.
It's like, look, there's
all these disciplines
and these different people doing research.
If they talk to each
other and they interact,
things can go really great,
you get this cross-pollination,
you can get these insights.
And that's true, I'm not denying that,
but...
cane codes and rabbits were
introduced into Australia
to pretty disastrous results too.
Sometimes,
you take something works
perfectly well where it is,
and you try and use it
somewhere else inconsiderately
and you get bad results.
So I'm gonna talk about a case
where I think people have
been getting bad results.
Hopefully, they'll stop doing it.
But also, as a general cautionary tale.
Now, sitting at the center,
this talk is gonna be some
claims about Bell's theorem
and the violation of Bell's theorem.
In an ideal world,
I could explain that for
people who don't understand,
if you don't know anything about it.
Tim Nguyen, actually, I did an
interview with him recently.
It's two and a half hours long,
and it'll go through
in all detail you want
what that's all about.
I'll just cut it to the
chase at a certain point
and tell you what Bell proved
and what the experiments proved.
And if you don't believe me,
it'll take longer to get to.
Okay, so...
Philosophers and scientists
often try to represent causal structure
in various idealized and simplified ways.
And I want to talk about, sorry.
Yeah, I gotta stay here,
this is gonna kill me.
In various idealized ways,
and their gross simplifications
and less gross simplifications.
I just want to talk about two ways
that philosophers have used to represent,
and scientists have used to
represent, causal structure.
This first one are examples
of what are called neuron diagrams.
There's a nice book by
Ned Hall and Laurie Paul
on causation that use a
lot of these diagrams.
And again, it's extremely idealized,
very simple, like binary kind of system.
The circles represent events
and the edges, the neurons,
are either excitory, or
excitatory, or inhibitory.
The ones with the arrows excite.
So the idea is, and time goes up on this,
so you have events at the bottom,
and then that can excite a later event,
and the little circles are inhibitory
so that'll prevent that from happening.
And then you can kind of read it upwards.
And then given such a diagram,
given the inputs at the
bottom, you sort of figure out,
given that's the structure,
what's gonna happen.
Now, these two diagrams are for an example
that Ned has used along a long time
that has these two kids, Billy and Susie,
who are just vandals and they're
throwing rocks at windows.
And they're both aiming
at the same window.
And this is a example in what's
called in the literature,
late prevention.
We can imagine they
throw at the same time,
but Billy's a little faster.
His rock is just ahead of Susie's.
His rock hits the window, shatters it.
Her rock sails right
through the broken window.
Even if he hadn't thrown, the
problem is, you might say,
"Well, how do I know that Billy..."
You say, "Billy, you
broke that window, right?"
But Billy can say, "Look,
if I hadn't thrown,
this window still would've broken, right?
Because her rock would've broken it."
So it's kind of causal over determination,
late prevention case.
So don't blame me, right,
if you use a very simple
counterfactual analysis.
And so these two structures
are obviously different.
They give you different causal paths.
The one on the left is
if Billy throws early
and the one on the right
is if Susie is slightly early, okay?
And you'll notice up there,
the only difference there...
Symmetric, except at the very end
where I've put that
little inhibitory thing,
that is, if Billy's goes through,
then not only does he break the window,
but he inhibits or prevents Susie's
from breaking the window, right,
'cause it's already broken.
And it's the other way around if she...
Now, the red circles
are supposed to be things
you might be able to control.
So the big question is,
if you have this very idealized picture
of the underlying causal structure,
okay, how can I figure out what
the underlying structure is?
'Cause there's certain things I can do
or I can observe, right?
Some things I can control,
some things I can observe,
some things are latent or hidden,
and this is what I'm trying to get at.
I can observe the result,
I can see whether the window broke or not.
And I'm imagining you can
have these two interventions.
You can, or you may or may
not stay Billy's hand, right?
Prevent him from throwing or
prevent her from throwing.
And then if you excite those things,
you'll see what happens, right?
What's clear is that if
you stay Billy's hand
in this diagram, if you
don't, he's gonna break...
The chain will be...
This causes, Billy's throw
causes the window to break
and prevents hers from breaking it.
If you stay his hand, then
those neurons won't fire,
hers will go straight through,
the window will break,
she'll be responsible.
And then you just reverse
the roles of Billy and Susie
if she's throwing a little faster.
Okay, so I hope everybody
sees how to read these things.
Now, you can ask, all right,
let's suppose we have
constraints on what we can see.
We can see actually
whether Billy, or Susie,
or both throw their rocks.
We can see whether the window breaks,
but we can't see the fine details
of the intervening process, okay?
And then what you...
That one back, sorry.
Then what you notice is that
from what we can observe,
we can't figure out which
of those two diagrams,
if either is correct,
because they give rise
to the same surface appearance, right?
What we'll find is that if we
stay neither of their hands,
the window breaks.
If we stay one or the
other of their hands,
the window breaks.
And if we stay both of their hands,
the window doesn't break.
But that's in common
between those two graphs.
So you have two different
underlying causal structures
that are giving rise to the
same empirical observations,
and therefore you now have
an epistemic problem, right?
You say, "I can't really be sure
what the underlying
causal structure is here."
Good.
Now, let's suppose we
can do something else.
Now I want to suggest, this
isn't in the literature,
I just wanna suggest something else,
which isn't usually talked about.
Suppose there's a different action.
Suppose I can't stay
Bobby's or Susie's hand,
but I can delay it, right,
just slow him down a little bit.
What effect can that have?
Well, suppose if I don't delay it,
they throw, Billy's a little
faster, his rock will hit.
So we're on this side.
But if I delay his hand enough,
so now Susie's rock is a little faster,
what I will have done is change you
from this causal structure
to that causal structure.
So that's a kind of meta
causation, if you will, right?
It's an effect on the
very causal structure.
But because I'm switching
between two causal structures
that are on the surface identical,
I also can't tell that.
I can't tell whether
my staying Billy's hand
had any effect at all, right?
Because in fact, on the causal structure,
'cause in fact, if he
had thrown first it did,
but if he'd thrown second,
it didn't matter that
I delayed him, right?
It's gonna be the same either way.
So I can't figure out the
counterfactual dependency,
I can't see the counterfactual
dependencies there.
Good.
And so this is the lasso.
In this case,
whether or not the delay
has any effect at all
cannot be gleaned from
the observable data.
If you give me the actual
underlying structure, of course,
I know if I know all the details,
I can tell you whether the
delay made a difference or not,
but I can't tell it observationally.
So what's the moral,
the reason that the delay
will have no observable consequences
is 'cause the two different
causal structures themselves
have all the same observable consequences.
Then, hence the effect of the delay.
Indeed, whether it had any effect at all
cannot be determined by observation.
And it's also obvious that
someone who can only see
whether or not the window breaks
cannot possibly tell
whether a delay was put in
on either Bobby or Susie, right?
So again, you have this other thing,
which is because whether
or not I put in this delay
has no observable consequences downstream.
I can't use it for signaling, right?
If I'm trying to, to
send somebody a signal,
and that person, all they
can see is the window, right?
And all I can do is either
delay Bobby or not delay Bobby,
I can't use my ability to do that.
I may be doing something,
I may be actually switching
the causal structure,
but I can't signal with it, okay?
This is a very simple
case where that happens.
So that's...
We would say in this setup,
I would call this a
no-signaling result, right?
Given the causal structure,
this intervention can't
be used to send signals.
It may actually have a
causal influence, right?
It may change the causal situation.
Now, the other thing,
I mean these neuron diagrams
are very, very simple.
You use them for
evaluating counterfactuals
and you use them for probing
certain counterfactual analyses
of causation.
A more serious thing that scientists use
are, of course, causal graphs.
They're much more subtle
because they're not just binary.
The neuron diagrams, either
the neuron fires or it doesn't.
It's just a very simple kind of thing.
But now, we again have these nodes,
we're gonna put down a directed graph.
We're gonna have nodes.
The nodes are connected to other nodes.
And one node firing can
have either an excitatory
or inhibitory effect
on whether the probability
of another node firing.
And...
in the neuron diagrams,
there's no probabilities.
It's all ones or zeros.
But, in a linear causal model,
and again, you're now
gonna be using these...
Sorry, you're gonna be using these
similar-looking directed graphs,
but they're different because
in a linear causal model,
the edges indicate a
kind of causal influence,
and that can have
different strengths, right?
So you also have to put
these numbers on the edges
that tell you how
strongly will the effect,
will the likelihood of the
effect go up or go down
depending upon how strongly
this thing is firing?
And the simplest case
mathematically, of course,
is for that to be a linear relation,
that, again, is obviously
a vast oversimplification.
In the real world, all
these things are nonlinear,
but for small variations,
you can always approximate
something pretty well linearly.
So we have this.
A linear causal graph is, again,
a self-consciously a great idealization,
but you can calculate the stuff.
So it's nice.
Now, you have the same problem,
and this has been the
subject of a lot of research
and really active research.
I was around when Clark
Glymour was doing this stuff,
starting this stuff back in the 1980s,
about the same time Judea Pearl
was looking at these things.
You set up these graphs, and
then you can notice, again,
there are certain things
you can control or observe
and other latent nodes you can't.
And more importantly,
the actual underlying structure is latent.
You can't see the underlying structure.
So what you're trying to
do is see what you can see
and then infer what you can infer
about the underlying structure
from the actual data.
But what you immediately see
is just as in the Billy-Susie case,
there are gonna be lots of these graphs
where they'll give rise to
the same observable behavior,
even though they have a
different underlying structure.
And the other thing you see immediately
if you do the combinatorics
is that as soon as you
get a lot of these nodes,
the combinatorics kills you.
I mean, the number of
different directed graphs,
you can write down, goes very high.
I mean, what Glymour was
working on at the time
was search, right?
How do I cut down the search
space of graphs I look at?
Because I can't look at all of them,
it's just not practical.
The usual constraint, in this case,
you're using directed acyclic graphs
because you think of
these edges as causation
and you think causes have
to proceed their effects.
So the causes can't go
around in circles, right?
So that automatically cuts you
down to the acyclic graphs.
But still they're way too many of them,
easy to calculate how many.
So here, you have to assign these weights.
Now, another funny thing happens here,
which is because you're
assigning these weights,
what you expect to happen
is gonna depend on the
exact weights you put down.
And another thing is from a certain node,
you can have multiple of these edges
that represent different
causal influences, right?
Or you can have an edge that
goes from here to this one
and another edge that goes
from this, to this, to that.
And some of them can be excitory
and some of them can be inhibitory, right?
When we give people vaccines,
there's one edge that's inhibitory
from your getting the illness,
but unfortunately another edge,
if it's say a killed live vaccine,
some number of people actually
get the illness, right?
So there's some chance you'll
be worse off if you take it,
there's some chance you'll
be better off if you take it.
It really depends a lot on
the weights of those nodes
to figure out whether you
should take the vaccine, right?
But then once you see that, you say,
"Well, for very, very, very
special values of these weights,
I can actually cancel out
an excitory and inhibitory effect."
So it's zero net effect, right?
I'm giving people all these vaccines
and I see no difference at
all in their sickness rates.
And one thing you say is,
"Look, vaccine's not doing anything,"
but it could be, "No,
no, no, it's actually...
It's actually creating
more sickness in this group
and preventing sickness in that group."
And in fact, different
people would've gotten sick,
but the statistics would be the same
because these effects just
cancel each other out.
Now, one of the things that
happens in this literature
is then people say, "Well..."
All right, this is what, okay.
So I already said that you
need to constrain these graphs.
One thing you do is by temporal order.
That means you don't allow
retrocausation or causal cycles.
Now, here's where I am.
So there's the vaccine example.
I've already said this stuff.
You can set weights
so that the net effect
will be statistically zero
even though it's actually
having causal effects.
And so what people do is they say,
"Look, we've got all of these graphs.
We're trying to cut down the number
of possible causal structures
we're considering."
Just don't take them seriously
if they're fine-tuned in that way, right?
So there's this principle
called faithfulness
or no fine-tuning
that basically says if
you've set up a graph
and you've put these weights on it
such that a manipulation you can do here
has causal connection to
something observable here
but you don't see any statistical changes
because of everything's canceling out,
just ignore that.
That's fine-tuning.
That's possible, but very implausible.
Don't believe it.
It's like fine...
I mean it's the same fine-tuning people...
We've talked about in cosmology.
How fine-tuned is the initial state.
How bad is fine-tuning?
That's all perfectly fine.
And what you'd like to do,
and this is what Glymour was
doing and Pearl was doing,
was just say, "Okay, what
good principles do I have
that will take me from the observed data
to plausible, underlying causal structures
constrained in part by the data,
constrained by other theoretical
considerations sometimes?"
But you see the problem,
you just have this over
generation of possibilities,
and again, the more latent nodes.
And in a lot of cases, most
of these nodes are latent.
I mean this was about
like with the monkeys,
what data can we get, right?
I've got all of this
incredible causal structure,
but I can only get my hands on the poop.
Okay, well, what can
I do with that, right?
So anyway, so that was a
piece of methodological advice
that comes in a reasonable way
out of the linear causal graph program
that says if you've got a
theory that's fine-tuned bad,
but then you say, "Well,
what's the indication that
the theory is fine-tuned
and now what they use?"
Notice if I fine-tune the theory
so that changing this variable here
has no statistical difference there,
I also get a no-signaling theory, right?
I can't send a message from here to here
by twiddling this knob
'cause you've set things up.
So no matter how you turn over the knobs,
the observable statistics anyway
will be the same at the other end.
So then they say, "Oh, so
here's the piece of advice.
If there's no signaling
between this and this,
there should be no causal
connections, right?"
Reject a theory that
has causal connections
between two nodes.
If you can't see,
if you can manipulate one
and you can see the other,
and these manipulations
don't make any statistical difference.
All right, so that's
the methodological moral
that comes out of that tradition.
You say, "Yeah, of course
logically it's possible
that you've got a causal
connection there."
Logically, it's possible.
But if you can't signal,
your best advice is to throw
that graph away, right?
Throw that theory away,
say it's bad, right?
Fine-tune, bad, bad, go away.
This was underlying for
people who know this stuff,
this kind of consideration
was underlying Glymour's work
on the tetra equations,
which is also Pearl
learned a lot from them.
Okay, there's this history
there I don't wanna go into.
Now, the problem that happened
is that this piece of
methodological advice
has been wildly oversimplified
to this idea that,
"Gee, if you can't signal
between here and here,
then you should never accept a theory
that has a causal connection
between here and here, right?"
You're violating this principle.
And so I've put it down
at the bottom here.
If there's a causal influence
of the input on the output,
then you should be able to signal, right?
You should be able to
cause an observable change
in the statistics of the
output by varying the input.
The problem is, so that basically says,
"If you've got no signaling,
then that implies no causal connection.
And if somebody has a theory
that has a causal connection,
throw it away, right?"
You haven't empirically refuted it,
but it's methodologically bad.
Now, what we've already seen
is that when we just looked,
forget about...
Go back to the neuron diagrams.
You can't really
fine-tune a neuron diagram
'cause it doesn't have these
weights in it to fine-tune.
It's all just this binary response stuff.
And what we saw in the
case of Billy and Susie
is you can have some of these diagrams
where there are causal connections,
but you can't use them to signal
because of the way the inhibitory
nodes have been put in.
Right?
And since...
So here, since there are
no edge weights at all,
the word fine-tuning can't
be the right word here.
I mean, the picture of fine-tuning
really is you've got a
radio with all these knobs
and you're very carefully
setting a whole bunch of knobs
to get a particular result.
You're not doing that here, you
can't do it in a neuron doc,
you don't have those knobs.
And so in such a case
where you've got two
different causal structures,
nothing fine-tuned,
they have the same empirical consequences.
There just may be nothing
to favor one over the other.
And you should just admit that.
You might say, "Look, one or
the other disease is right,
we're just epistemically
blind to it, right?
We can't get at which one is right
because we have no direct access
to the underlying structure."
So, to get us now,
I'm going to get us to
the result here, I hope.
So, if there is signaling, right?
If I have a variable here
and I can freely set it however I like,
and on the basis of doing that some,
there's the observable statistics
of something else changed,
then I've got a good Shannon
transmitter right now,
I can apply Shannon information theory.
I can say, I want to tell you,
"Are we gonna go to lunch?"
I manipulate this, you look at the data,
you say, "Oh, you did that. Okay."
So it's certainly reasonable
demand that if you can signal,
you better have some causal
connections there, right?
The problem was, right,
and you regard one of these
variables as a free variable
if anybody hasn't read John Bell's paper
on free variables in local causality,
which is just about this and
he hits all the right notes,
I recommend you read that.
I think that's a perfectly
reasonable advice, right?
If you can send signals,
then yeah, there better be a causal path
running from the
transmitter to the receiver.
Now, I should mention here,
when you say there's a causal path,
it's kind of an abstract thing.
It doesn't mean there
has to be a particle,
or energy, or anything like this.
Standard example is Sherlock Holmes,
the case of the dog in the night, right,
where Sherlock Holmes...
There's a signal that goes
from the happenings in the barn
out to the house where Sherlock Holmes is
or where the people are.
Why? 'Cause the dog didn't bark.
So there was no energy,
there was no particles,
but there was a signal.
Why? Because of the
counterfactual structure.
If the murderer had been a stranger,
the dog would've barked,
they would've heard it.
They didn't hear it,
ergo the dog didn't bark,
ergo the murderer was a familiar, okay?
That's a perfectly good Shannon signal,
even though there's not a physical process
that takes it from here to here.
Now, the main thing I want to say.
You should not turn that
good piece of advice
around into a bad piece
of advice that says,
"If you can't signal,
there can't be any causal connections."
Now, you might...
Right, because although signaling
does indicate at least a
possible causal process,
if you will,
inability to signal
doesn't indicate lack
of causal connection.
Like, the example I gave
you, I delay Billy's throw.
That really does have an
effect on the causal structure.
It still doesn't allow you to signal
because of the way things are set up.
So it's the gap between these,
the gap between causation and signaling
is one of the things
that sends right at the
center of Bell's theorem
and Bell's inequality, you might say.
But if I can't send a signal,
why should I think
there's a causal connection at all, right?
What's my grounds?
'Cause that's a good empirical grounds.
And what Bell proved,
and this is where I would give
you the proof if I had time,
that there are certain kinds of statistics
that cannot be recovered from
any locally causal theory.
That is where if you separate
two labs far enough apart,
nothing that's done in this lab
can have any effect on that.
Nothing that's done or happens in that lab
can have any effect on this.
So that's a locally causal theory.
Everybody thought the
world was locally causal.
Einstein sure thought the
The thing he was always
upset about quantum mechanics
was that it wasn't local
and he always complained about telepathy
and spooky action at a distance.
What Bell figured out is that
in any locally causal theory,
there are certain restrictions
on the sorts of statistical correlations
between what happens in these labs, right?
So I'll just kind of...
What's gonna happen
is we're gonna create a pair of particles
or sometimes a triple of
particles here at the center.
That's the preparation
of the entangled state.
That's red 'cause I can
control that, right?
I know what particles I'm creating.
I send a particle out to
Alice's lab on one side,
the other particle out to
Bob's lab on the other side.
Alice and Bob each have a choice
of how to set their
experimental apparatus.
So those are red circles
and those are their free
manipulable choices.
They can make them however they like.
And David has done a lot of work
about making them in funny ways.
Both of those clearly
are causally relevant
to what happens in the experiment, right?
And the experiment gives rise then
to some observable output.
And the statistics we have
are about the statistics
of the correlations
between we know Alice's
choice, we know her output,
we know Bob's choice, we know his output.
We know what we prepared,
that's always the same,
that doesn't vary in these cases,
so that's straightforward.
And if it was a causally local theory,
because Alice is way over here
and Bob is way over there,
you're not allowed to put an arrow
going from anywhere on Alice's side
to anywhere over on Bob's side, right?
That's what you're just
prevented from doing.
And what Bell showed is that
if you don't have those,
there are constraints on the statistics.
You can see when you compare
what happens in this lab
to what happens in that lab.
Now, what happens is quantum theory
predicts violations of those constraints
and then what happens even better
is the actual world
violates the constraints.
That's what the Nobel Prize
in Physics two years ago
was about,
was experimental
verification of violations
of Bell's inequality.
So now, you get a clear thing.
I have to put arrows, right?
So there has to be some arrows
going one way or the other, right?
This shows the world isn't locally causal.
So if I want to causal diagram,
I've gotta have these distant causation.
What can I do?
Well, this is now should
remind you of Billy and Susie,
I hope.
I can put it that way.
I can say, "Oh the thing
is set up so that in fact,
some of what Alice does
or what happens over there
has an effect on Bob."
Or I can run the causal
thing the other way.
Of course, if you do this
in a kind of symmetric way,
it won't surprise you that
like the Billy and Susie case,
empirically, it won't make any difference
which way the arrows go, right?
The statistics are gonna be the same.
So you can't tell from
the surface statistics.
You can tell there is an arrow,
but you can't tell
which way it runs, okay?
So that becomes empirically
hidden from you.
Now, what determines which graph...
Are you-
- [Moderator] Almost done.
- Trying to, okay, I'm almost done.
So I wanna say it's gotta be...
It's gotta be one of these two graphs.
What determines which graph it is?
In the case of Billy and Susie,
the question was the
timing of the rocks, right?
Was it this one or that one?
Here, it's essentially the
timing of these experiments
that are done distantly.
The obvious way to take
care of this is now,
and now I have to say, I'm sorry Albert,
relativity is wrong.
You put in what's called
a preferred foliation.
You put in essentially a
kind of global time function
so that you can say who went first.
You can't do this in relativity.
So you're giving up on relativity,
you're giving up for good reasons.
If Alice went first, then it's this graph.
If Bob went first, it's that graph.
Now is that fine-tuning, right?
Now, you can easily see,
you can set this up.
So you can't tell from
the surface statistics
who went first.
You can't use this to send signals.
All right, I'll just...
So they're detailed examples
in pilot wave theory,
you exactly understand how this goes.
I'm just gonna skip over this
'cause obviously I'm running too late.
And in the collapse theories,
it goes a different way,
but I can't back that up.
So let me just say, in
both of these cases,
in the pilot wave theory,
in the collapse theories,
you have no signaling theories.
Bell started these.
He not only proved this,
he proved what's sometimes
called the Bell telephone theorem
that says, "Even though there
has to be this connection,
you can't use it to signal."
And that just follows
from certain understanding
of the dynamics.
And I'm just going through
why you get also no
signaling and collapse.
All I want to say at the end of this
is that if you look at
any of these theories,
they are not, in any
intuitive sense, fine-tuned.
There's no little parameters
that have been set.
There's no careful adjusting of any knobs.
It's just what determines what cause
what is the actual order in time,
and relative to this foliation
the actual order in time.
That's a fact, it's a physical fact.
We may not be able to get
our hands on it, okay?
I would even say that in these cases,
it's in a way Billy and
Susie are slightly fine-tuned
'cause they have to throw their rocks
pretty well-coordinated.
But because this just
matters on who goes first,
it doesn't matter.
There's no fine-tuning like that.
You got these two events,
one's earlier than the other.
So that's...
Just saying that that piece
of methodological advice,
which is drawn out of the
linear causal graph tradition
and then thrown over
inconsiderately, I would say,
over to this example.
And people have used it to say,
"Oh, pilot wave theory, that's no good."
"Why not?" "It's fine-tuned."
"What do you mean it's fine-tuned?"
"Oh, go read the linear
causal graph literature."
That's all that's happening
here and it's bad.
It's really harming.
It's harming reasonable
discussion of these cases.
So I thought since I was with
people who do this stuff,
I would make a plea to stop doing that.
Okay, I think that's the end, right?
Yeah, so in sum, good, so the
methodological rule to avoid,
or even forbid fine-tune causal models
where the criterion of fine-tuning
is no signaling is
completely inappropriate
in the context of these tests.
If the inequality is violated,
the Bell's inequality,
that alone implies some
non-local causation,
no theory that's Bell-local
can make these predictions.
It doesn't mean you can tell empirically
which direction the causation goes,
but the inability to do that
does not imply fine-tuning
in any substantial sense of the term.
So that's that.
- Thank you so much
(audience applauding)
We have time for one
quick question, Naftali?
- [Naftali] Yeah, thanks for your talk.
Yeah, so I totally agree
with what you've said
about fine-tuning.
And I just want to get
clear on, so I mean I...
Someone might see this talk
and think the lesson is that
you shouldn't use causal models
to think about these scenarios.
Well, at least what I...
Yeah, what I would suggest
is just you should actually
know what you're talking about
because as you pointed out,
yeah, faithfulness does
not equal fine-tuning.
So.
- Oh, right.
- Great, let's thank all the
speakers from this morning
and head out to lunch upstairs.
(audience applauding)